hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan I'm Jeff
and it's time for game squad years let's
begin Oh
[Music]
first up the Nintendo switch catalog
just keeps on growing in the hotly
anticipated announcement that Shin
Megami Tensei 5 would be coming to the
west has now been confirmed the initial
announcement of the next core entry in
the Shin Megami Tensei series was
entirely in Japanese leading some to
believe the game wouldn't be localized
for the Western market Atlas has now
confirmed that a Western release is
planned and if you want to check out the
reveal trailer in English you can do
that now too as someone whose game of
the year is persona 5 this is all good
news Atlas has confirmed that the game
will be released in both North America
and Europe as for the game itself Alice
has said it will be set in modern Tokyo
as most games in the series are the
press release dates that players will
face a new onslaught of demons in the
latest from the highly acclaimed series
so we can look forward to that next up
holy crap you guys need to be careful
while playing Pokemon go a new study has
revealed that a bunch of car accidents
and property damage has been caused by
players playing Pokemon go the study was
produced by researchers at Purdue
University we focused on police reports
from Tippecanoe County Indiana
the reports revealed that five hundred
thousand dollars in damage 37 injuries
and two fatalities from car wrecks can
be attributed to the Pokemon go craze
the research teams scaled up the results
to estimate the effect on the entire US
and extrapolated that the game may have
caused an increase of over 140,000
accidents 250 fatalities and 2 to 7
billion in economic costs take care
while your Pokemon hunting friends
finally set a project red has the engine
for cyberpunk 2077 all up and running Oh
hopefully we won't have too long to wait
now then Oh probably still a while to me
well in a recent interview with a Polish
business website president Isetta Prague
Adam Kaminsky revealed that their
proprietary red engine is all updated
and ready to go red engine has been
updated with each game with the latest
iteration being used for the witcher 3
there is he also said the engine is
being constantly updated to meet the
needs of the specific title the studio
is working on elsewhere in the interview
he revealed that 300 people are
currently working on cyberpunk 2077 more
than had worked on Witcher 3 during peak
development when asked for a release
date though Kavinsky refused to comment
but did say to wait patiently for an
official announcement could it be soon
could it be not soon could it be later
could it be now
who knows that is everything we have for
you guys today do let us know what you
thought about today's stories down in
that comment box and we'll be back with
a bunch more news tomorrow I
double-hand a wife lucky ducks